bioinformatics is the intersection of
informatics or the science of processing
data for storage and retrieval and
biology the study of living organisms
this field developed tremendously in the
last several decades transforming life
sciences enabling biotechnology and
empowering biomedical research
as a result came many new discoveries
that include new treatments for
different diseases diagnostic assays
design strategies for experimentation
and innovation in biotechnology as a
result there is a growing interest among
biologists and clinicians for data
including new types of data generation
computational methods of analysis as
well as approaches to find patterns that
can explain biological phenomena
a lot of breakthroughs in bioinformatics
are a result of high throughput
technologies like next-generation
sequencing that generate billions of
data points on genes proteins and other
molecules which characterize biological
systems
these data are compiled into
repositories that can be systematically
studied to understand and establish
trends for many applications one such
repository is maintained by the national
center of biotechnology information
which has a collection of peer-reviewed
articles biological data sets and
projects on various topics
the introduction to bioinformatics
program will introduce you to these
important terms and topics as a result
of completing the course you will see
the applications of next generation
sequencing biostatistical methods of
analysis and computational tools that
are used to process and mine big data
the training program combines biology
and data analysis concepts leveraging
the omics logic portal
there you will find a collection of
training modules that will help you get
started the program is designed to point
you to the relevant resources and
complete them over the course of the
semester
these resources will introduce
bioinformatics applications in
healthcare biomedical research
biotechnology and agriculture
provide you with a concise overview of
various biological concepts that you
need to know to understand omix data
introduce you to big data analysis using
several example data sets and expose you
to coding in r and python that are used
to analyze biological data
these are just several examples that
will lead into more in-depth review of
key omix technologies and analysis
methods
after this overview you will be able to
see how next-generation sequencing data
and bioinformatics are used in various
research areas like oncology infectious
diseases neuroscience and agriculture
you will also be introduced to the t
vitamin for platform for big data
analysis where you can run analysis of
large data without any technical
expertise
avoiding the challenges of piecing
together complex analytical pipelines
that typically bioinformaticians do
to see the full schedule we welcome you
to explore this page and start with your
journey into bioinformatics